what's going on uh my name is dalton
i've been listening to the show off and
on for a while now
just want to say i love everything you
do gang gang
but uh a couple gang baby onward sorry
to interrupt you
but a couple of episodes ago i think it
was on the swipe society episode you
mentioned some about your uncle or i
forget who got hit by a train
oh yeah um my mom's brother
got hit by a train i didn't know him
he was dead or i was
i wasn't dead i wasn't alive yet so i
was before you know
i guess i was dead i was you know i just
wasn't alive so
you're not alive when you die and then
you
you're i guess
i don't know if it's dead i don't know
what i was i wasn't i wasn't on earth
and he was already on earth and then he
got hit by a train he was alcoholic
he was alcoholic and he got hit by train
and that's all i know oh and he was um
brunette
let's hear more
he died and
i can relate because uh when i was in
high school it was probably like
10 years ago i was actually hit by a
train
uh on the way to school i was walking to
school and
i lived
and uh
yeah i don't know if you want me to i
can send you damn send me what a dog
you gonna send me some arms son i'm just
joking man
wow
that industrial alarm clock baby that
train
gang baby and you hitting the hot line
we got miracles on the hot line let's
play more go on dalton
an article link to the article or
whatever but
it was a life-changing moment for me
like
basically i survived this accident and
if i could go back honestly i wouldn't
change a thing i would probably
get you know i wouldn't change i would
probably you know still get hit by
such a life-changing moment for me
yeah
that's what's up baby i'm upstairs
that's who we are dawg
we are people that get hit by trains and
say run it back fam
we out here dog
god
can you believe it's a miracle riley
isn't it yeah
this man been
he said he said bring it back
let's hear more
that
it was so it was probably the most
important thing
to happen to me in my life it really put
things into perspective but uh
yeah i just wanted to share that though
dang baby he want he he said bring it
back train
two trains
let's run it back
that's powerful man because that it's
like
i gotta listen to this one well it's
like something happens to you
and it's really
rough it's really bad
and you say that was the greatest
experience let's hear this again this
accident and
it was a life-changing moment for me
like
basically i survived this accident and
if i could go back
honestly i wouldn't change a thing i
would probably
get you know i wouldn't change i would
probably you know still get hit by yeah
such a life-changing moment for me
it was so it was probably the most
important thing that has
to happen to me in my life that's what's
up
we getting hit by trains baby
man it's just like
that's that look man thank you for
calling don't i just
you know i'm sitting here complaining
about this in my life and this is tough
for me and this thing you know and this
is hard and i have this and we got a man
out here
who's getting hit by train
and says hey
let's make it trains baby
who's saying let's run it back fam line
up again
satan
with your big dirty machine
line up again gerald ford or whatever
that guy's name is
whom you know
the train guy larry amtrak whoever it is
line it up
and let's do it again baby because i'm
i'll go one more time that's powerful
that's powerful man
i mean you know
do you feel do you feel the you feel i'm
lifted up here riley
i'm lifted up man because
you know it's like
there's just so much to be learned
through pain
and to get through it and say let's do
it again
i want more
to look your pain in the eyes and say i
want more
because i'm gonna be i'm gonna be
toughened up
i started off as a damn soft shell crab
i'm gonna finish out as a turtle baby
i'm gonna be toughened up
wow you got me lifted dalton
that's powerful baby
thank you man
thank you very much
thank you for the call you uh
what else you get pubic hair riley male
you get how's your body doing overall
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices some guy just brings you one
option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one
you